>> Jesse: WANT TO KNOW HOW BAD
THINGS ARE FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
A NEW POLL OUT TODAY.
PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL RATING 34%.
WHAT YOU CALL CIRCLING THE
DRAIN.
IT MAKES SENSE CONSIDERING
EVERYTHING WE ARE LEARNING.
THE NEW BOOK BY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" BLOWS THE LID OFF THE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES DRAMA AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
A LOT IS FROM KAMALA HARRIS.
A TOTAL DIVA.
SHE AND JOE ARE NOT ON THE BEST
TERMS.
THEIR WEEKLY LAUNCHES ARE
AWKWARD.
TWO PEOPLE SITTING AT A TABLE
TOTALLY SILENT.
WE GOT SOME VIDEO OF THE LUNCH.
WATCH.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Jesse: IT'S REALLY BAD.
THIS IS JUST A TASTE OF THE
BUFFET OF GRIEVANCE.
READY?
APPARENTLY THIS IS ACCORDING TO
THE "TIMES" SO IT HAS TO BE
REAL.
KAMALA HARRIS IS FED UP WITH JOE
BIDEN'S MOSTLY WHITE INNER
CIRCLE.
THEY DON'T GIVE HER ANY RESPECT
SHE SAYS.
PROBABLY BECAUSE THEY'RE RACIST
BECAUSE THEY ARE WHITE.
SHE IS MAD THAT PEOPLE DON'T
RESPOND LIKE THIS WHEN SHE
ENTERS THE ROOM.
>> ♪ ♪
>> [CHEERING].
>> Jesse: TO BE FAIR.
KAMALA HARRIS ONLY DEMANDS
PEOPLE STAND FOR HER.
WHO DOES SHE THINK SHE IS IN
BRITISH ROYALTY?
WITH ALL OF THE COMPLAINING
SHE'S DONE ABOUT HER NEW LIFE IN
THE SPOTLIGHT, SHE COMES OFF
LIKE MEGAN MERKEL.
HER "VOGUE" MAGAZINE COVER TOTAL
MELTDOWN.
THIS WAS PUBLISHED 2 WEEKS
BEFORE THE INAUGURATION.
KAMALA HARRIS DIDN'T LIKE THE
PICTURE BECAUSE SHE WAS WEARING
SNEAKERS.
SHE PUT THE SNEAKERS ON AND TIED
THE SHOES BUT DIDN'T LIKE THAT
THEY WERE IN THE COVER.
SHE WANTED TO LOOK MORE
ESTABLISHED.
[LAUGHING].
WELL, THEN THIS.
THAT TITLE WE HAVE GIVEN HER THE
BORDER CZAR, SHE HATES IT.
SHE WANTS TO NUMBER CHARGE OF
RELATIONS WITH THE NORDIC
COUNTRIES INSTEAD OF THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE.
SHE WOULD HAVE RATHER BEEN SENT
TO COPENHAGEN INSTEAD OF CENTRAL
AMERICA.
VERY MAD ABOUT THAT AND THE
WHITE HOUSE LAUGHED AT HER WHEN
SHE SAID THAT.
IT DOES EXPLAIN HER OBSESSION
WITH ROOT CAUSES.
>> WE ARE FOCUSSED ON ADDRESSES
THE ACUTE FACTORS AND THE ROOT
CAUSES.
AFTER TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE
ON THE ACTUAL ROOT CAUSES AND
INVEST IN THE ROOT CAUSES.
THE OVERALL ISSUE WHICH IS ROUTE
CAUSES.
YOU CAN'T JUST REACT TO
A PROBLEM WITHOUT SOLVING IT AT
ITS ROOTS.
>> Jesse: I BRING ALL OF THIS UP
TO SAY THIS.
JOE, KAMALA HARRIS, IF GUYS WANT
TO BE ON THE WINNING TEAM WE
HAVE GET RID OF ALL OF THIS
DRAMA.
COME ON, YOU ARE BETTER THAN
THIS.
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS THE FORMER
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS BEFORE?
>> NO.
CERTAINLY NOT WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND THE VICE-PRESIDENT I WORKED.
TRUMP AND PENCE.
FOR EVERYTHING ABOUT THEIR
RELATIONSHIP OVER THE LAST YEAR,
THE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS IS
ONE OF INTRIGUE.
THE STAFFERS ARE AT EACH OTHER
THROATS.
I WAS IN THOSE LUNCHES WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THE
VICE-PRESIDENT.
THEY HAD A WEEKLY LUNCH, TRUMP
AND PENCE EVERY MONDAY.
LOOK, A COUPLE OF THINGS ARE
GOING ON HERE.
JOE BIDEN AND JILL BIDEN WAS
RIGHT ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS FOR
THE WRONG SEASON.
JOE BIDEN SAID F-HER ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS TO A GROUP OF
SUPPORTERS THE DAY AFTER THE
DEBATE IN WHICH KAMALA HARRIS
CALLED JOE BIDEN A RACIST BUT
MADE IT ABOUT HER AS A LITTLE
GIRL.
JOE BIDEN SAID IN A BOOK F-HER
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE WAS RIGHT TO BE UPSET
ACCORDING TO THE BOOK.
JOE BIDEN WAS RIGHT TO BE UPSET
HER HUSBAND CHOSE KAMALA HARRIS
BUT THIS IS A PERSON THAT KAMALA
HARRIS HAS NO PURPOSE AND NO
REASSURANCE TO THIS COUNTRY.
HER OWN STAFF EXITING DOESN'T
MAKE THE NEWS BECAUSE IT'S SO
COMMON.
HER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
RESIGNED.
THIS HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
INCLUDING AFRICAN-AMERICAN
STAFFERS HAVE LEFT HER AND PRESS
SECT.
IT'S FOR A SIMPLE REASON.
SHE CAN'T DO THE JOB.
AMERICANS LOOKING AT THIS AND
SEE THIS.
KAMALA HARRIS AND JESSE WATTERS
AND KELLYANNE CONWAY HAVE ONE
THING IN COMMON.
EACH OF US RECEIVED ZERO
ELECTORAL VOTES.
THIS WOMAN COULD NOT GET
A SINGLE ELECTORAL VOTE FROM THE
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU ARE AMY KLOBUCHAR OR
WARREN, WRONG ON THE ISSUES, BUT
THEY CAME CLOSER TO BE THE
NOMINEE THAN KAMALA HARRIS DID
AND WERE PASSED OVER FOR VP FOR
THIS WOMAN WHO CAN'T DO THE JOB.
SCHOOL CHILDREN CAN MEMORIZE
THINGS.
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
THE VICE-PRESIDENT CAN MEMORIZE
SOME THINGS AND MAKE US FEEL SHE
SUPTO THE TOUGHENING.
-- TASK.
THIS HASN'T HAPPENED.
>> Jesse: IT HASN'T.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL EVER
HAPPEN